Another source of error cited at
that symposium was an incorrect
system default.
This can occur in at least two ways.
A particular EHR could have been set
up to default to a particular value,
and the provider may overlook
that while charting.
Another, and
far more insidious possibility
is that EHR remembers the values
from a patient's prior visit to save
the physician time in charting this one.
The obvious potential
error is to document
what may have been correct last time,
but is wrong this time.
Another source of error derives from
the desire to save the provider time
by fitting as much as possible
onto each data entry screen.
This can lead to a cluttered
and/or illogical layout
that can cause information
to be overlooked.